28 - 6,6 footballeurs ont quitté le
groupe france
on connaît désormais le nom des heureux
sélectionnés pour le mondial aimé
jacquet a mis fin au suspense dans la
matinée jean philippe guillemard félix
11h45 ce matin et me jacky met fin à un
long suspense et confirme ce que les
sélectionnés français savait depuis hier
soir de 28
la liste des joueurs est enfin ramené à
22 non c'est un choix qui élimine un
gardien les dix y ait cinq joueurs de
champ l'aigle j'ai tout lamouchi anbari
et anelka bien sûr qu'une décision et 17
c'est dur c'est même très cruel mais
nous vivons dans un monde cruel
donc à partir de là et il faut en
accepter ou faut faire autre chose même
s'ils ne l'avouent pas tous clairement
les joueurs semblent soulagés et
respecte le choix de l'entraîneur c'est
pas juger de la manière j'ai pas à juger
du choix simplement il est clair que
quelle que soit la manière quel que soit
le choix
ça fait toujours des malheurs dire les
inquiétudes on était un groupe de 28 je
pense 28 bons joueurs donc on peut
s'attendre ça fait partie du métier je
pouvais faire partie des six nations
d'autres comme si dan deschamps 42
djorkaeff était sûr d'être du voyage et
pouvait dormir sur leurs deux oreilles
même ceux qui sont partis ils ont prouvé
qu'ils pourraient faire partie de
l'équipe de france donc c'est ben vrai
que c'est bien c'est pour ça ils sont
partis par la grande pompe à barra
petite porte
voilà donc la fameuse liste tant
attendue
elle allie expérience et jeunesse 12 des
joueurs convoqués étaient déjà présents
lors du championnat d'europe en
angleterre
en 1996 le groupe définitif s'envole
lundi pour casablanca au programme deux
rencontres amicales contre la belgique
et le maroc au passage dugarry et henry
qui font un peu figure de repêcher de la
dernière heure pourront peut être prouvé
que le maillot tricolore les inspire
dans vingt jours la france débute en
coupe du monde face à l'afrique du sud